peer review is not a simple thing
because humans do it and so whenever
there's humans that will be bias
introduced relationships get complicated
with regard to peer review we have a
fantasy the peer review will be totally
anonymous on both ends you won't know
who the person you're reviewing is and
they won't know who you are and it will
all be blind but in reality people
figure out in peer review who is who and
biases do get introduced but that said
the ideal of peer review is a really
important one and we can sort of
approach it and that's the idea that we
have people who are qualified judging
each other's work it allows us to
essentially crowdsource knowledge and to
have an opportunity where blind spots
are picked off where errors are picked
up and where we can make work better so
it's a essentially a way to crowdsource
knowledge I want to point out by the way
that peer review is historically really
interesting it came out of the
Enlightenment period so this was the
period when thinkers were beginning to
really appreciate the idea that humans
together could know more and what's
fascinating is that democracy and
science grew up together and they both
use peer review so science uses peer
review because scientific ideas are put
forth and then scientists are qualified
to do so judge that work and in
democracy peer review is used in things
like voting systems so when we do voting
that's a peer review form when we do
judging of criminal or non criminal acts
in courts that's a form of peer review
and we have a jury and so it's not a
coincidence because what was happening
was the thinkers of the Enlightenment
were beginning to figure out that more
people looking at a problem could get
you better knowledge before the
Enlightenment the concept was knowledge
came from above they came from the
church from the state from God it came
from an external higher authority but
the real revelation of the Enlightenment
was the idea that people could do this
themselves they didn't have to rely on
the church the state God an external
Authority they could do it themselves
and so they began to have the idea that
they would reject the king and they
would essentially reject the teachings
of the church and they would reject the
state being run by the king that they
would take back control of knowledge and
that was true in democracy and in
science
so it's no coincidence that a lot of the
founding fathers were science geeks they
were thinking about crowdsourcing it's
what we call crowdsourcing there are
more checks and balances on bad
knowledge going forward so there's
accountability at some level right when
you you're doing peer review the editor
at least knows who you are
when you're doing voting theoretically
you're not allowed to vote more than
once when you're on a jury you've got a
judge keeping track of whether or not
information should be admissible in
court whether it's fair to admit it in
court the internet is crowdsourcing gone
wild it has no limits on it and so you
can have things like BOTS like things
until it actually is noticed by real
human beings you can have situations
where something looks incredibly real
but it's not real and it will take off
much faster than we can stop it
so the Internet really is a beautiful
thing in many ways it allows people to
find each other who never could have
found each other before for example
people with very unusual medical
conditions can find each other people
with very unusual interests can find
each other the problem is that you have
a situation where there are no checks
and balances and so you get a phenomenon
whereby things that are not real can go
forward but there are some places on the
internet where there are checks and
balances so Wikipedia is a great example
actually Wikipedia actually has people
who function as editors and they will
talk to each other fight with each other
and all the discussions get externalize
that allows a level of accountability
that much much of the internet doesn't
have it's also the case that Wikipedia
paid editors can actually stop people
from editing in some circumstances or
stop people from messing with pages so
there are places on the internet that
have been born of crowdsourcing but that
do have some checks and balances built
in
[Music]